How's it going everyone and welcome back
to this week's video. This week we are
going to be talking about midweek
reversal and this is the second video in
our weekly profile series. Let's get
into the PDF. So what is a midweek
reversal? Well, that is when the midweek
forms a reversal or Wednesday forms a
reversal. So generally what is this
going to look like in a bearish week?
We're going to have Monday and Tuesday
go opposing the bias. So if we are
bearish, those are generally going to be
bullish days. Then Wednesday is going to
form a candle to closure or a reversal
candle. From there we trade in our
intended direction and we have Thursday
and Friday forming expansion candles. So
the days we want to focus on are
Thursday and Friday or if you want to
trade candle two, you can also focus on
Wednesday. Now with a bullish week, it's
the same but just opposite. Wednesday's
going to form the reversal. We want to
see Monday and Tuesday opposing that
bias. So with us being bullish, we want
to see Monday and Tuesday go lower which
helps to form this weekly wick. When
Wednesday confirms this reversal, we can
then look to trade Thursday and Friday.
So what does this actually look like?
Here you can see in the bearish
scenario, we have a bearish candle to
closure. Monday and Tuesday have gone in
the opposing direction of our bias and
this helps form the wick of the weekly
candle. With this candle to closure,
what do we want to look for? We want to
check inside there and see if we have an
hourly change in the state of delivery.
This confirms this daily high which
helps us to confirm the wick high of the
weekly candle that we can trade away
from. Now it's the same thing but just
reversed in the bearish scenario. Monday
and Tuesday oppose our bullish bias.
Candle two closure on Wednesday. We
check inside that candle two to make
sure we have an hourly change in the
state of delivery and with that we can
look to trade higher on Thursday and
Friday or candle three and candle four
of the fractal model. Now with this
we're going to look to trade that
expansion until it's average daily range
or until our higher time frame objective
is met.
So just review. Monday and Tuesday
oppose our bias. Candle two closure
created on Wednesday and then we can
look to trade Thursday and Friday. Let's
get into some examples in TradingView.
So in this first example, we have a
Friday reversal. So this is where we can
be looking for Monday to continue lower.
What do we have for targets? Well, we
have a swing low right here. So let's
see what Monday does. And in this case,
Monday and Tuesday are combined together
due to a bank holiday but we run out
this low here. Now is this a candle
closure in which case we can look to
trade price higher in line with this
trend? No. So what do we need to do? We
need to wait for another day.
Now here we have another day. Here we
have a candle two closure which is in
line with our higher time frame bias
which is higher. So if you notice we
have Monday and Tuesday, in this case
it's one candle, opposing our
anticipated bias. It is going lower when
our bias is higher. And what do we also
have now? We have failure swings on the
high and we have high resistance
liquidity on the low. So now that we
have a candle two closure with a small
opposing run and you can see that can
make a small wick on the weekly time
frame, what do we want to look for next?
We want to go down to the hourly time
frame. Down here on the hourly time
frame, we want to see what do we have.
Do we have a change in the state of
delivery? We do. And we also have an SMT
off of the low. So here we can look for
price to trade higher because what? It
is a continuation day. Candle two has
reversed. It has a change in the state
of delivery. We've anticipated that this
weekly low has formed with this daily
low and we can look to see this trade
higher. Now what do we have for targets?
Well, looking here, we have this target
right up here on the left and that is
our previous daily high. And you can see
our first little target here. We get no
reaction. So we can see this continue
higher.
Now we go and hit this target here.
Now we have this next day. Why can we
still be looking for a continuation on
Friday here? Well, we have Wednesday
reversal, Thursday continuation.
Thursday closed strong and we still have
an open objective on Friday. So this is
where we can get a continuation on
Friday into that final objective.
And there we go. You can see we have hit
our final objective. Let's go out to the
daily chart just to review this really
quick. Monday and Tuesday, in this case
it is one singular candle, opposes our
anticipated bias which is higher. So we
have that small opposing run. Wednesday
forms a candle two closure or the
reversal day. This is paired with a
lower time frame change in the state of
delivery on the hourly chart and then we
get a continuation on Thursday and also
a continuation on Friday as we have that
open objective. So that is a Wednesday
low of week where Monday and Tuesday can
oppose the weekly range. Wednesday forms
a reversal and we get a continuation on
Thursday and Friday if we have open
objectives. So not every weekly profile
is going to be picture perfect. You have
to stop expecting that and to just apply
it to a template. You have to actually
use this with the phases of price and
some logic. So what do we see here? You
can see we have a range high in which we
have swept out and then we have traded
through this range low. So what are we
looking for at a range low? We want to
see do we retrace to continue lower? Do
we reverse to continue higher? Or do we
form a consolidation in which case we
can look for a manipulation to trade
lower or manipulation to trade back
higher? So we want to let a few candles
form to tell us that.
Let's see what happens. Here you can see
we do form a swing point. So I want to
see does this next candle expand higher
so we're forming a reversal or does it
form a new reversal in which case this
can be a retracement to continue lower?
And here you can see we go take out this
little high right here and then what do
we do? We don't quite have a candle two
closure but we do have a reversal
looking candle. So this is telling me
that it looks like expansion into
retracement to continue lower. Now
lacking a candle two closure, I could go
to the lower time frames and look for
more confirmation but I prefer to have
that closure to lines with it. Even if
Wednesday here is to form the high of
the week, I'd still want to let Thursday
form or get some more confirmation on
the lower time frames. Let's go down to
the hourly time frame here.
And so coming down here to the lower
time frame, what do we see? Could we
look for a trade on this Thursday here?
Sure but that is not super clean. I
would prefer to let this daily candle
close and tell me what? That it actually
did form the high of the week. So here
now with a candle three closure and this
change in the state of delivery, we can
say that Wednesday has formed the high
of week and we can look for a
continuation on Friday. So this is an
example of when we have a Wednesday high
of week but it's not a clean reversal on
Wednesday. This is when we can let
Thursday form and then look to trade the
continuation on Friday once that's
formed. So what do we have? We have
Friday and we have these failure swings
below. Let's see if we get a
continuation lower.
And you can see there we do go get a
continuation lower into the lows. So we
go back out to the daily chart here and
look at the weekly profile. What do we
have? We have expansion, retracement
into a new expansion. Monday, Tuesday,
Wednesday, they all oppose the weekly
range. We're letting Thursday.
Thursday's actually the confirmation
that Wednesday has formed the high and
then we can look for the continuation
lower here on Friday. So this is just an
example of once again, everything is not
going to be picture perfect. Now would I
prefer to have a clean candle two
closure here on Wednesday with a change
in the state of delivery and a V-shape
reversal to trade Thursday and then
trade Friday? Yes, but it's not always
going to be the case. And in this case,
I just get one day of clean daily bias
this week. So let's get into another
example. So here we are in our next
example and once again, it is not a
picture perfect example.
What is the first thing that we noticed
is this is our last swing point. We have
not formed a new swing point. So I want
to let a new swing point form before I
can trade away from it. Here you can see
Monday we expand higher. Tuesday we form
a reversal candle. So if we form a
reversal candle or a candle two closure,
what could we be looking for Wednesday
to do here? To go back lower into either
react in a fair value gap here or here
to form a swing point we can look to
trade higher. So let's see what happens.
Here you can see we do get that
reversal, right? So we have the bearish
expansion. That bearish expansion is
reversed out of a point of interest and
we can see if this candle two closure
can trade higher. Now what is this doing
on the weekly time frame?
We are looking to see is this weekly low
being formed by a daily swing point? If
this daily swing point forms, the weekly
low has formed and we can look to trade
it higher. So what do we notice here?
Candle two closure, we need to go to the
hourly time frame, check to see do we
have a change in the state of delivery?
And there you can see we do have a
change in the state of delivery. So on
this next day, it is okay to be bullish,
right? We're aligning these time frames
together. We've anticipated the weekly
low to form on the weekly time frame. So
this gives us a green weekly candle with
a green anticipated daily candle and
then our hourly is also aligned with
that. So let's see what happens.
You can see we expand higher here.
Now with a pretty strong closure here,
we could look for this to trade higher
or a continuation into the following day
on Friday here. Wednesday reversal,
Thursday continuation with a strong
closure on Thursday. We can also see a
Friday continuation.
So letting that play out.
You can see a small continuation but we
do reach into our previous day high and
higher. So just to rewind and review
here, what are we waiting for? We're
waiting for what we can anticipate to be
the weekly low to form. We can
anticipate that with the daily closure
here on Wednesday with the hourly change
in the state of delivery. And that gives
us two days of bullish bias.
So here we are in another example, and
what do we notice? You can see we have a
nice V-shape here, and then we have a
consolidation.
And why is this a consolidation? Well,
there is an inside bar, so we can use
this consolidation to look for a range
to trade off of.
So let's wait for the next day to form.
You can see that we remain internal to
this range on Monday, Tuesday. And then
we want to see what happens on
Wednesday.
Wednesday, you can see we sweep out this
range low, and we also have a candle to
closure. Now this isn't as ideal of a
candle to closure because you can see
it's also somewhat of a bearish
expansion candle. So what do we want to
look for if we are going to look to see
this trade to the other side of the
range?
We want to look inside this candle and
see if there is an hourly change in the
state of delivery.
So going down here on the hourly chart,
what do we have? Right? I'm going to
clean up the chart. And do we have an
hourly change in the state of delivery?
No, not yet. Because we find this low,
we find the series of candles that meet
it. Has price closed over this level?
No. So we need to wait for price to
close over that level to confirm it.
Now, going intraday, we'd want to see
what if we are bullish? Open, low, high,
close. So we do want to see price open
first, form a low, then go and close
over this. Confirming both the daily
profile as well as the weekly profile.
And here you can see we do have that
open low. We're closing over. So now we
have every criteria met to be looking to
trade this higher into what? The failure
swings above. So let's see what happens
here.
Here you can see we do get a nice
expansion there on Thursday. So
Wednesday reversal, Thursday
continuation. And then going into
Friday, we can be seeking a continuation
here. And what do we have? A nice
protected swing going into that day.
So letting this continue, you can see we
also get another expansion on that day
here.
So just to review, what do we have? We
have a Wednesday reversal, right? And
it's not a great candle closure, so we
want to use more confirmation on the
lower time frames. In this case, the
hourly. Going into the hourly, we have a
protected low we can be looking to trade
away from. Price opens, forms its low,
confirms the weekly profile as well as
its daily profile, and then expands
away. Because it closes strong on
Thursday, we can also be looking for
Friday to continue as well. So going
back out to the daily chart here to
review this, you can see we have a
range. We sweep out the range low on
Wednesday, forming a reversal. Thursday
gets a continuation. And then Friday
also gets a continuation.
So that's another example of a midweek
reversal or Wednesday forming the low of
the week. I'm trying to give you a
variety of examples here. Not
everything's going to be picture
perfect. Some closures are not going to
be great. But at the end of the day,
that is what weekly profile is more
useful for. Is when you don't have that
picture perfect fractal model.
So with that, I hope you enjoyed the
video. If you did, please consider
liking and subscribing, and I'll see you
guys next
Have a good one.